Hoy vamos a hablar de la República Democrática Popular de Corea. El único país cuyo nombre,
en sí mismo, es una ironía. Hablamos de
una nación que lleva 70 años gobernada
por la misma familia. En el gobierno de PYONYANG,
el cargo de jefe del estado es hereditario.
Y ¡Ojo! Que no se llama el Presidente ni
el Rey. El título oficial que ostenta Kim
Jong Un es el de LÍDER SUPREMO.
En fin ¿Qué podemos decir de Corea del
Norte que no hayáis oído miles de veces?
Se trata de la dictadura más salvaje del
planeta, donde las torturas, las ejecuciones
y la extrema pobreza son algo más que habitual.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué nos preocupa
tanto este país? Pues bien, la respuesta
es tan sencilla como que tienen bombas atómicas. Hablamos de un país que oficialmente sigue
en guerra con Corea del Sur, que está lanzando
amenazas continuas contra Japón o Estados
Unidos y que cada x tiempo realiza pruebas
de su arsenal nuclear en sus costas. En otras
palabras, que hay razones de sobra para tomarse
al Querido Lider en serio.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué, siendo tan
peligrosos, nadie se atreve a pararles los
pies a Corea del Norte? Pues bien, una de
las razones por las que la comunidad internacional
continúa respetando a esta dictadura es
su amistad con China.
"China y Corea están tan próximos como
los labios a los dientes" --Mao Tse Tung
Sin embargo, las cosas ya no son lo que eran. China se está empezando a cansar de tener
que estar defendiendo continuamente a su hermano
tonto. Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué
China y Corea del Norte están enfriando
sus relaciones? ¿Y qué consecuencias puede
tener esto para el futuro de este país?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas. Y
lo vamos a hacer de la mano del mayor experto
de China que hay en todo youtube. Sí, amigos
de VisualPolitik, estoy hablando de CHRIS
CHAPPELL, el presentador de CHINA UNCENSORED.
¡Hola Fonseca y un abrazo a todos los amigos de VisualPolitik! Efectivamente, las relaciones
entre China y Corea del Norte se han deteriorado
hasta tal punto, que han empezado su particular
guerraa de palabras! Básicamente, China
dice que está dispuesta a trabajar con los
malvados imperialistas, es decir, los EEUU
para combatir el programa nuclear norcoreano.
"China dice que está dispuesta a colaborar con EEUU para frenar el programa nuclear de
Corea del Norte"
Entonces, los medios estatales norcoreanos
respondieron que China debería reflexionar
sobre este "acto irresponsable que romper el pilar de las relaciones sino-norcoreanas"
y que tendría graves consecuencias.
"China deber"a ponderar las graves consecuencias
que traerá romper el pilar de sus relaciones
con Corea del Norte"
Después, los medios estatales chinos respondieron
con una clara amenaza de acabar con esta alianza.
"¿Está desactualizado el tratado de
amistad entre China y Corea del Norte?"
En otras palabras: China y Corea del Norte estan muy cerca del divorcio ¿Pero por
qué? ¿Qué ha pasado para que se dejen
de llevar bien? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
CHINA FRIENZONEA A COREA DEL NORTE
Tras la II Guerra Mundial, Japón retira
sus tropas tanto de China como de Japón.
Ambos países se dividen en dos facciones,
una comunista y otra anticomunista. Ambos
países comparten frontera. Y tanto la China continental como Corea del Norte terminan
estando dirigidas por sendos líderes que
defienden el marxismo en su versión más
radical. Como os podéis imaginar, estas
dos naciones estaban llamadas para entenderse.
Y así ha fue. Durante 70 años, la República
Popular China y la República Democrática
Popular de Corea han sido como Quentin Tarantino
y Robert Rodriguez.
"Hoy en día, China no sólo envía ayudas
económicas. También presta dinero al gobierno
para el gobierno norcoreano para que pueda
construir carreteras, ferrocarriles, etc
Incluso si Pyonyang no puede devolver las deudas, Pekín se lo perdona
También está el petróleo. Durante décadas, China ha sido el principal proveedor de zumo
de dinosaurio en Corea del Norte.
Además, está la ayuda militar. China ayuda a entrenar a los hackers norcoreanos, hackers
que ahora son una amenaza a la comunidad internacional,
incluida la propia China.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué recibe Pekín
a cambio? Por un lado, tienen un aliado con
armas nucleares, que siempre puede venir bien
si las cosas se ponen muy, muy mal. ¡Pero
no sólo eso! Corea del Norte también es
un paraíso de mano de obra barata. De hecho,
muchos productos con la etiqueta de "MADE
IN CHINA" son, en realidad, "MADE IN NORTH
KOREA"
"La firma de ropa deportiva RIP CURL ha
pedido disculpas públicamente después
de descubrir que uno de sus trajes de ski
han sido hechos en una de las fábricas estatales
de Corea del Norte"
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque las cosas están empezando a cambiar. En las últimas
décadas, China no sólo se está abriendo
económicamente sino que también quiere
establecer relaciones diplomáticas con el
resto del mundo. Imaginad lo difícil que
es tratar de llevarte bien con EEUU mientras, a la vez, tienes que justificar que tu aliado
quiere bombardearlos. Complicado ¿verdad?
Pero la cosa va mucho más allá. Hace 60
años, Corea del Norte y China eran países
muy parecidos. Pero hoy en día, las cosas
son muy distintas...
"Estos turistas han venido a ver de cerca
la experiencia miserable de sus vecinos norcoreanos.
(...) No soy mayor pero creo que lo que estoy
viendo ahí es muy parecido a como estaba
nuestro país en el pasado"
Muchos de estos norcoreanos matarían por poder cruzar la frontera con China. Y Pekín
tiene miedo de lo que podría convertirse
en una crisis de refugiados similar a la que
está ocurriendo con los sirios.
Por si esto fuera poco, la diplomacia de
Pyonyang no es precisamente muy "diplomática" con sus propios aliados. Aquí tenéis un
detalle cortesía de Kim Jon Un.
"Un grupo de pop femenino creado por Kim Jong Un ha cancelado, de manera abrupta, un
concierto en Pekín y se ha vuelto a Pyonyang"
Pero sin duda alguna, febrero de este año
2017 ha sido el momento de ruptura de esta
bonita amistad.
El hecho de que Corea del Norte lance misiles
nucleares para demostrar su poderío militar
no es nada nuevo. La novedad es que China
está dispuesta a criticarlo.
Todo esto ocurre en un momento en el que el Presidente Chino, Xi Jimping, intenta mejorar
sus lazos con Estados Unidos. Y, por supuesto,
para los ojos de Pyunyang esto es una puñalada
trapera. Esto ha desatado toda una guerra
de declaraciones entre estos dos países.
¡Pero la cosa no se ha quedado en simples palabras! ¿Recordáis que China había
formado a esos hackers surcoreanos que hace dos años habían pirateado los servidores
de varias productoras de Hollywood? Pues ya sabéis...
"cría cuervos y te sacarán los ojos"
"Esta ola de llamados ataques RANSONWARE
han golpeado duramente a China. Si Corea del
Norte fuera responsable, aunque no fuera a propósito, sería el primera intento conocido
por parte de Pyongyang de robar en las arcas de China a semejante escala"
En otras palabras, que si no cambian mucho las cosas, Corea del Norte habría perdido
a su único aliado. El único país dispuesto
a defenderles ante una potencial guerra. Una
guerra que, aunque sólo fuera por motivos propagandísticos, muchos querrían librar...
PUTIN Y TRUMP ENTRAN EN ESCENA
Sé lo que estáis pensando "Fonseca,
menuda historia más turbia nos estás contando!
¡Sólo falta que aparezca Vladimir Putin
para que esto sea un auténtico vídeo de
VisualPolitik! Bien pues... Aquí los tenéis!
"Rusia ya controla el suministro de combustible
para aviones para Corea del Norte después
de que China hubiera interrumpido sus exportaciones"
Rusia y Corea del Norte también tienen muchas
cosas en común... aparte de compartir frontera,
ambos países tienen líderes fuertes, atractivos y viriles.
Y en ambos países, los derechos humanos se consideran opcionales.
"Rusia y Corea del Norte han puesto un servicio de ferry que conecta los dos países, de
tal forma que las empresas rusas pueden recibir la mano de obra esclava norcoreana." Significa
esto que Putin y Kim son ahora coleguitas...?
Mmmm... pues no del todo... nuevamente, Kim Jong Un tiene un sentido un poco raro de la
amistad...
"Corea del Norte lanza un misil en el mar cerca de Rusia"
A ver, Kim Jong Un, hijo mío... ¿Tu crees
que esto son formas? Pues no, no lo son. Como
os podéis imaginar, con detalles como este, Rusia tampoco está por la labor de defender
a Corea del Norte a capa y espada. Así que, por primera vez en la historia, el Estado
más odiado del mundo se ha quedado sin aliados...
¡Y aquí es cuando, por fin, entra Donald
Trump!
"Tenemos un gran problema, alguien no esta haciendo lo correcto... y esto va a ser mi
responsabilidad"
Todo esto, mientras China intenta firmar un acuerdo de libre comercio con Estados Unidos.
A la vez, Donald Trump no gana para escándalos en su propia casa. Incluso algunos diputados
del propio partido republicano están empezando a hablar de plantear una moción de censura
por el escándalo de las filtraciones a Rusia...
Así que la pregunta que queda en el aire
es ¿Podría Donald Trump invadir Corea
del Norte para apuntarse un tanto y ganar
puntos de cara a sus votantes? ¿Puede ser
este el fin de la dictadura de Corea del Norte?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis conocer a fondo todos los detalles de la ruptura entre China
y Corea del Norte, tenéis que visitar China
Uncensored, que es un canal centrado al 100%
en mostrarnos la política y sociedad china.
Y si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
la próxima!